what we're going to do in this video is
give ourselves a quick introduction to
carbohydrates and you might already be
familiar with the notion if you look at
a some packaged food there's usually a
nutritional label and it'll say
carbohydrates it'll tell you a certain
number of grams per serving and not all
carbohydrates are edible but many of the
things that we eat or many carbohydrates
are edible and many of the foods we eat
have some carbohydrate component to it
but what's actually what is it actually
well we could look at the word and we
see carbo so maybe it has something to
do with carbons and it says hydrates so
maybe it has something to do with water
and if you said that you'd be pretty
close because carbohydrates do involve
carbons in fact this is a very typical
carbohydrate a very simple one right
over here this is a glucose molecule and
in gray you see that it has six carbons
and the hydrate part refers to that
carbohydrates typically have oxygen to
hydrogens in the same ratio as you would
expect in water so for every one oxygen
two hydrogens and you see that right
over here where in glucose you have one
two three four five six oxygens and you
have 12 hydrogens and so this that's
where this word comes from
now another word that is often used
interchangeably with carbohydrates is
the term saccharide
saccharide and saccharide comes from
greek for sweet and that makes sense
because if you were to taste glucose it
would taste sweet to you
now what's interesting about something
like glucose is glucose can be a
standalone molecule a very simple sugar
in this case or you can build up larger
molecules with really glucose as a
building block so for example right over
here we have a part of a glycogen
molecule and you can see it's just a
repeating sequence of glucose molecules
and so something like this we would call
glucose a monosaccharide it's one simple
sugar right over here monosaccharide
and we would call this glycogen a
polysaccharide
poly
or another way to think about it is
glucose is the building block for the
glycogen another term you might see is
monomer and polymer those are the
general terms of if i'm building a large
molecule out of a chain of smaller ones
the building blocks we would consider to
be monomers and then the thing that we
build out of those monomers could be our
polymer and as we'll see this monomer
polymer phenomenon is not limited to
carbohydrates or saccharides we're going
to see that same relationship for
example between amino acids and proteins
now what role do carbohydrates play
inside of biological systems
well saccharides or carbohydrates are
often associated with a source of
energy
glucose can be converted very quickly to
energy in biological cells glycogen is
also a store of energy in your liver and
your muscles and once again it can be
broken down into the glucose molecules
which once again is a very readily
available source of energy
now in plants especially some of these
polysaccharides could also play a
structural role if we're talking about
things like cellulose which is another
polysaccharide so there's also a
structural role
now i will leave you there we have
focused only on one type of
monosaccharide in glucose and only on
one
type of polysaccharide in glycogen as we
will see glucose does show up a lot but
there are many other types of
monosaccharides and there are many other
types of polysaccharides and
polysaccharides in particular are part
of a broader group of molecules known as
macromolecules
and as you can imagine from the
macro prefix it's referring to
large molecules oftentimes that have
thousands of atoms in them but don't get
the wrong idea they're very large at an
atomic level but each of these circles
are still atoms so you would still need
a very very very very powerful
microscope to even take a look at even
some of the largest macro molecules
including polysaccharides